[Musik]
[Applaus]
das sind unsere gäste heute und hier ist
unser thema russlands präsident
verhandelt über einen krieg mit dem er
angeblich nichts zu tun hat er
rechtfertigt einen mord für den er
nichts den auftrag gegeben haben will
wladimir putin macht ist seinen
fürsprechern im westen nicht leicht
frankreichs präsident marco versuchte es
trotzdem
russland sei nicht mehr der feind sagt
er und sendet liebes größe nach moskau
für die deutschen kommt diese wende
reichlich überraschend aber auch berlin
muss viel erklären wieso kauft man
erdgas von einem land gegen das man
gleichzeitig aufrüstet wir müssen reden
mit diesen gästen annalena baerbock die
grünen-chefin fordert europa muss sich
emanzipieren denn putin und tram wollen
uns spalten
vladislav belov der experte vom europa
institut in moskau ist sicher putin hat
mit seiner politik vieles richtig
gemacht
edmund stoiber der langjährige
bayerische ministerpräsident findet eine
schrittweise aufhebung der sanktionen
wäre richtig heiko maas der
bundesaußenminister sagt wenn die gründe
weiter bestehen werden wir die
sanktionen verlängern und claire dem ist
die frankreich expertin sagt makro ist
von deutschland enttäuscht seine
annäherung an russland hat strategische
gründe
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
[Musik]
anlass ein mann die zuschauer ist auf
offener straße erschossen worden
diese tat stellt die deutsch russischen
beziehungen auf eine harte probe
ein mord mitten in berlin eine
diplomatische krise und eine düpierte
kanzlerin
vier monate ist es her im berliner
bezirk morbid fallen schüsse
sie treffen am helllichten tag einen
georgier der im tschetschenien krieg
gegen die russen gekämpft hatte sein
mutmaßlicher attentäter sitzt in
untersuchungshaft
hat er im auftrag des russischen staates
getötet
bundesanwalt es nicht mehr und nicht
weniger
bislang seien die russen wenig
kooperativ gewesen
die bundesregierung verweist zwei
russische diplomaten des landes setzt
aber weiter auf entgegenkommen
ich gehe davon aus dass die russische
seite ihre informationen und zur
verfügung stellt jedenfalls fände ich
das gut helfen
neben ihr sitzt vladimir putin und
erwidert die höfliche zurückhaltung der
kanzlerin mit eiskalter rechtfertigung
der getötete sei ein gesuchter mörder
und blutrünstiger mensch verantwortlich
für zwei terror anschläge unter anderem
auf die moskauer u-bahn russische seite
hat mehrmals darum gebeten diesen
bewaffneten verbrecher diesen banditen
auszuliefern
leider haben wir keine übereinkunft
erreicht er mitnehmen
angela merkel schweigt dazu später wird
die bundesregierung einen solchen
auslieferungsantrag der russen
bestreiten
cdu-außenexperte norbert röttgen wundert
sich auffällig ist dass offensichtlich
präsident putin dieser fall und die
identität des ermordeten gut bekannt
sind
sollte sich herausstellen dass diese tat
sich in das muster russischer
auftragsmorde auf ausländischem
territorium einreiht bedarf es einer
weiteren europäischen reaktion der
bundesaußenminister ist bei uns heiko
maas heute haben die russen ihrerseits
zwei diplomaten ausgewiesen und den
deutschen botschafter eingestellt
einbestellt wie geht es jetzt weiter
und da erst mal hat uns das so sehr
nicht überrascht dass das eine
gegenreaktion in russland gegeben hat
der fall ist für uns relativ klar der
generalbundesanwalt hat die ermittlungen
in diesem mordfall an sich gezogen das
ist sehr ungewöhnlich der
generalbundesanwalt ermittelt in
terrorismus oder auch wenn auftragsmorde
eben von einem staat ausgehen und darauf
mussten wir reagieren vor allen dingen
aber auch deshalb weil die russischen
behörden die ja ihren weiter hätten
leisten können wenn das nicht so ist
sich keinerlei keinerlei informationen
weiter gegeben habe und das
zusammengenommen hat uns dazu gebracht
dass wir sagen wir wollen eine
diplomatische reaktion haben zwei
russische diplomaten ausgewiesen um auch
den kollegen in russland deutlich zu
machen wir sind mit diesem verhalten
nicht einverstanden dass man keinerlei
aufklärungsarbeit leistet und sagen sie
jetzt auch wie die bundeskanzlerin sie
wünschen sich mehr zusammenarbeit oder
gibt es von ihrer seite eine härtere
reagiert wenn ich würde sagen ich
erwarte dass also wenn das ja so wie das
von der russischen seite gesagt wird
nicht so sein dann kann man es relativ
einfach aufklären
das verstehe ich nicht warum man sich an
dieser aufklärung nicht mitteilen
und deshalb werden wir uns jetzt
anschauen wie das ermittlungsverfahren
beim generalbundesanwalt verlaufen wird
und je nach dem werden wir uns auf
weitere schritte vorbehalten
bei uns ist wladislaw below fair ist
deutschland experte beim europa institut
in moskau
herr bierhoff jetzt sagt der russische
präsident der ermordete sei ein bandit
gewesen und russland habe sich um seine
auslieferung bemüht sagte er damit nicht
wenigstens indirekt dass russland ein
motiv für einen mord gehabt hätte aus
draht nur ein motiv gehabt
dass deutschland auch mit arbeitet wenn
die verbrecher oder dem mörder auf dem
territorium dann um eine gezielt suchen
und dann hier dann auch zu hause sind
wenigstens kontext und putin ist wenn er
an georgien auch dann der stadt der auch
an dieser person interessiert war das
kann georgier in china aber er hat die
bürgerschaft von georgien gehabt der
wehr am leben geblieben und putin hat
angedeutet also mann zitiert und bandit
also es mörder nach neun quälend dann
beziehe ich dann auch zu natürlich auf
radio business fmc hat auch schreckliche
angaben oder also nicht die was auch
nadine putzen genannt hat er hat
tatsächlich an verbrechen hat schuld er
hat natürlich sollte dann auch vor dem
gericht stehen und was auch dann wenn
putin im contest gesagt hat schade dass
er nicht vor dem gericht gestellt worden
war
er wäre am leben geblieben ob das
georgien oder russland da gibt es keine
langlebigen strafen wir auch in
deutschland und in diesem sinne diese
also das war schon auch eine reaktion er
hat schon auch von der oberen gesprochen
herr seifert hat als bestreitet hat
gesagt bestritten man das auch erde
braucht oder auch dann auch von der
russischen seite daran teilnimmt wie
gesagt also putin hat angedeutet
also das ist nicht instrument von den
russischen politik und findet er dass
man sagt dass es auch dann russlands
bürger der jetzt auch dann im gefängnis
kalkulatorische unterstützung bekommen
von sonder botschaft aber vermeintliche
attentäter nur um das noch mal zu
erklären aber vielleicht haben wir
gesagt also wie gesagt putin sagt das
war nicht der auftrag und nicht das ziel
und mittel der russischen politik
ich hatte danach gefragt ob es
wenigstens ein motiv gegeben hätte herr
maas noch mal die zwei dinge putin sagt
es hat ein auslieferungsersuchen gegeben
ohne erfolg die bundesregierung sagt das
stimmt nicht das stimmt dass die
bundesregierung
und es ist in den ermittlungen bisher
ersichtlich dass wir es bei dem opfer
bei dem späteren opfer mit einem
islamistischen attentäter zu tun hatten
es ist relativ schwierig im nachhinein
das zu klären es gab keine ermittlungen
es gab auch keine informationen wie sie
da nicht angefragt worden
jemanden auszuliefern und sind es noch
nicht gesagt wurde was ihm vorgeworfen
wird das kommt jetzt alles so im
nachhinein das hört sich ein bisschen
nach rechtfertigung an also es hat schon
finde klingt schon komisch deshalb
werden wir uns jetzt anschauen was der
generalbundesanwalt erst einmal in
diesem verfahren ermittelt da wird es
auch motive gehen sicherlich wird auch
das opfer dort noch einmal überprüft
werden
aber jetzt zu kommen und zu sagen na ja
dann hätte die er schon längst
ausliefern können es ist einfach nicht
so gewesen diese vorwürfe die jetzt
erhoben worden sind in der vergangenheit
der bundesregierung nie mitgeteilt
wurden
und all das wird bei uns dazu dass wir
das nicht einfach so akzeptieren können
im übrigen wäre das bei jedem anderen
staat genauso der sich so verhalten
würde
deshalb empfinden wir das was die russen
heads gemacht haben ist vielleicht eine
klassische mit klassische reaktion nach
diplomatisch im regelwerk aber in der
sache nicht so recht hatte edmund
stoiber sitzt rechts neben ihnen herr
stoiber ehrenvorsitzender der csu jetzt
wünschen sich viele dass es einen
neustart der deutsch-russischen
beziehungen geben soll wäre ein solcher
auftragsmord ein guter erster schritt
dahin natürlich nicht es ist ein
schwerwiegender vorgang und auch für all
diejenigen die immer sich auch bewegen
das verhältnis der nachbarn deutschland
und russland da deutschland oder
russland europa zu verbessern sind
natürlich auch sehr betroffen weil das
spielt natürlich atmosphäre ist ein
riesen rolle nachdem
nach dem gipfel in paris stichwort
ukraine
jedenfalls war die atmosphäre gut und
man hat ja glaubt jetzt könne man
sozusagen auf den etwas aufbauen und
dann kommt das was richtig sagt dass es
ist außerordentlich dass der
generalbundesanwalt hier selbst die
ermittlungen an sich zieht und vor allen
dingen nach hin meist der verdacht eines
verbrechens liegt vor
das muss aufgeklärt werden die man wir
können das hier natürlich eigentlich nur
spekulativ diskutieren aber es ist ein
zeichen
und man muss ja auch sagen es ist ja
auch etwas machen wir erinnern uns
global in london wir in unseren
politkowskaja in moskau wir in unseren
an dem zoff den ehemaligen
ministerpräsidenten ich noch
kennengelernt hatte die alle sozusagen
ermordet werden und es ist immer ein
hauch von von ein problem wie weit ist
das sozusagen auch staatlich unterstützt
in der empörung sind sich viele einig
annalena baerbock einer der zwei
vorsitzenden von bündnis90 die grünen
die müsste ich jetzt aber eine harte
reaktion gegenüber russland aussehen
wenn man die denn befürwortet nah wie
hier deutlich wurde es noch nicht
ausermittelt deswegen kann man jetzt
auch nicht weiter spekulieren aber klar
ist auch die reaktion des russischen
präsidenten
wir leben ja in einem rechtsstaat wir
leben in einer demokratie und da ist
vollkommen unabhängig was eine person
vorher getan hat oder nicht
auftragsmorde das ist keine
rechtfertigung dafür dass jemand
vielleicht vorher was anderes getan hat
und gerade weil es ja in der ganzen
frage nicht nur darum geht wie sind die
beziehungen zwischen russland und der
europäischen union wir leben auf einem
kontinent da muss man natürlich im
dialog sein sondern weil es auch immer
wieder darum geht was es eigentlich mit
unserer demokratie verteidigen wir als
europäer unsere grundrechte und
grundwerte muss man aus meiner sicht
hier eine deutliche sprache sprechen es
wurden zwei diplomaten ausgewiesen und
zugleich hat das auswärtige amt aber am
selben tag ein neues dialog format mit
höchster russischer ebene
eingeläutet fürs nächste jahr und da
stellt sich für mich dann die frage wie
viel ist da alibifunktion man weiß weil
diplomaten aus oder macht wirklich eine
klare ansage
es kann nicht sein dass wir auf
europäischen boden hier einen verdacht
haben mit einem auftragsmord vor allen
dingen was herr stoiber angesprochen
hatte nachdem wir das in großbritannien
und mit skripal ja schon einmal in der
europäischen union haben
da gab es eine große diplomatische
reaktion es wurden insgesamt 100
diplomaten ausgewiesen
aus deutschland 4 bei uns ist claire
denis mail sie kommen und arbeiten für
die deutsche gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik vor dem mm und wir haben sie
heute hier in die sendung eingeladen
nicht nur um über frankreich zu sprechen
sondern über die jüngste initiative von
emanuele makro mit großen schritten geht
er auf russland zu und auf moskau zu
meine erste frage ist eine theoretische
was wäre eigentlich wenn ein solcher
mord nicht in berlin sondern in paris
geschehen wäre
es wäre natürlich viel komplizierter für
marco jetzt seine russland initiative zu
verteidigen
frankreich hat mit dem fall nichts zu
tun ich gehe davon aus dass marco viel
vorsichtiger wäre aber trotzdem diese
neue priorität der russland politik
nicht unbedingt reservieren würde
das hat einen tiefen grund und das hat
auch mit seiner wahrnehmung von
internationalen gefahren
herausforderungen zu tun
und insofern micro hat zum beispiel in
seiner rede an die botschafter von der
destruktiven haltung moskaus gegenüber
der eu und gleichzeitig verteidigt er
diese initiative also er versucht das ja
auf beiden schienen zu gleichzeitig zu
laufen und wie wir alle wissen ist
gleichzeitig oder sowohl als auch und
ein lieblingsfoto in der politik braucht
man diesen die bleiben noch mal bei dem
gipfel für eine sekunde herbert wladimir
putin fordert ja immer mehr respekt für
russland russland soll respektiert
werden so zwingend geschätzt aber
respektiert werden als land und als ein
wichtiges land in europa zeigt er mit
solchen auftritten
in paris gegenüber angela merkel respekt
glauben wir natürlich aber noch einmal
mutter hat nicht rechtfertigt also keine
rechtsprechung des burschen und was hört
geben natürlich so gut kenne das schon
kontext egal was jetzt mit hiermit
tschetschenien und georgi passiert und
wenn dann gerne seite der russin biss
das macht putin
da sollte ich ihr dann auch sp
vorsichtiger sein und natürlich das
respekt ist dann die anerkennung
interessen im kontext von daten also
nicht nur interessant werden die dann
auch die gleichen wie in europa und
putin spricht darüber bitte unsere
politik verstehen und das ist gut und
richtig wäre es spreche nicht von putin
verstehen sondern tatsächlich dass
moskau offensichtlich interessen hat ihn
auch im europäischen kontext oder in den
anderen kontexten schon mit den
interessen von losen partnerin bereits
stimmen aber man vermutet immer das doch
das sind auch dann die worthülsen und
die sind nicht mit den taten gefüllter
kommen sofort an auch der mord der mord
also spital oder dann auch der getötete
natürlich dass da kann nichts passieren
und signal von putin war bittet dann
auch in betracht ziehen dass auf dem
territorium von europäischen ländern
die verbrecher gibt und dann kann man
auch damit nicht dann so umgehen wenn
das die verbrecher sind wenn es das
bewiesen ist bitte auch zusammen aber
das signal an berlin
weil es gibt genug aus diesem
tschetschenischen klick ohne namen ohne
bürger die tatsächlich dann auch
aber um diese zusammenarbeit hat in
berlin ja inständig gebeten und das
meine ich tempo informiert dass meine
und ich bin überzeugt dass es auch ist
nicht nur öde und diplomaten geht es
gibt eine innenministerium gibt auch
dann behörden ich weiß genau dass auch
dann die zuständigen organen sehr gut
kooperieren
ich war dann auch dann erstaunt das audi
dieser beschluss so schnell kam war es
gibt genug mechanismen das zu besprechen
er es ist schon etwas komisch wenn
das dann nachdem jemand getötet wurde
erklärt worden ist dass er straftaten
begangen hat an terroranschlägen
beteiligt gewesen ist aber vorher das
überhaupt keine rolle gespielt hat und
natürlich in technischen gründen
vermehrt dann aber nicht aber ich bin
ganz gut in der sache weil wir noch mal
nachgefragt haben da ist nix also weder
bei uns noch mit innenminister haben
auch bei den behörden die für
rechtshilfeersuchen zuständig sind also
das kam erst nachdem der
generalbundesanwalt die ermittlungen
eingeleitet
und trotzdem ich bin nicht der
auffassung dass das dazu führen kann
dass man den dialog mit russland
einstellen ja aber sie haben gleich
gesagt das wird gleichzeitig ein
dialogforum mit den bussen veranstalten
er das tun weil wir auch finden dass wir
die beides brauchen wir fordern putin
verlangt respekt für sich oder für
russland und wir verlangen auch respekt
für den rechtsstaat und wenn es nach
unserer auffassung verstöße gibt muss
das offen und klar ausgesprochen werden
dass wir mit russland reden müssen
ich meine das haben wir bewiesen wir
sieben stunden in paris zusammen an
einen tisch um eine lösung für die
ukraine dabei das wäre genau meine frage
herr maas wie redet man mit jemandem an
einem verhandlungstisch denen man eben
wenigstens unterstellt dass er
provozieren will der gegebenenfalls auch
hinter gehen will
der vielleicht auch die unwahrheit sagt
wie macht man das
sie können mir glauben dass da wo ist so
unterwegs bin man des öfteren leute
trifft bei denen man befürchten muss
dass wir auch die unwahrheit sagen wenn
ich diese gespräche nicht mehr führen
würde hätte ich deutlich mehr freizeit
und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt hat dass
das wesen der diplomatie darin besteht
nicht immer zu denjenigen zu gehen mit
dem man einer meinung ist also ist auch
gut das muss man auch machen um
bündnisse zu schließen
aber viel wichtiger ist dorthin zu gehen
wo schwierigkeiten gibt und wo man auch
auf schwierige personen trifft und wo
man auf schwierige politische
rahmenbedingungen bedingungen trifft das
ist eigentlich viel wichtiger und das
gilt natürlich auch für russland das ist
aber genauso möglich gewesen ist am
montag in paris
wirklich viele viele fortschritte zu
erzielen ist dieser unselige krieg in
der ukraine endlich mal ein ende
das zeigt eigentlich die bandbreite ja
man muss dort wo gegen recht verstoßen
wird eine klare sprache haben
aber dort wo man jemanden braucht etwa
um frieden zu schaffen muss man auch in
der lage sein trotz aller bedenken die
man hat und trotz auch der möglichkeit
dass auch dort die unwahrheit gesagt
wird muss man diese gespräche führen den
abschluss geht's in der ukraine zum
beispiel um die leute die da leben in
der ost ukraine und die jetzt in den
sechsten kriegswinter gehen und wir
werden alles daran setzen auch in den
gesprächen mit russland wir werden uns
in vier monaten wieder treffen
dass das der letzte kriegswinter für
diese leute gewesen ist
herr bierhoff wir sind damit ist das
schiff wort gegeben seit 2014 herrscht
krieg in der ukraine russland spricht
immer noch von einem in der ukrainischen
konflikt glauben dass wenigstens in
russland alle menschen nicht
hundertprozentig gibt auch die anderen
meinen es gibt dann müsste bekannt die
alternativen die dann auch an der seite
von rheine stehen aber wenigstens eine
völkerrechtliche dass das auch eine
innere mission konflikt und wo auch
russen dann auch besteht dann zum
beispiel sind von minsk kommen und dass
die breiten publikum im
verfassungsrechtlichen feld von ukraine
bleiben also es geht nicht darum dass
auch russland interesse gehabt hätte da
kann ich mit können nicht vergleichen
also müssen besteht darauf dass auch
dann die bürger in diesen auf diesem
territorium die rechte haben und
garantien haben damit darüber hat aber
kurz angesprochen dann wenn es auch die
kontrolle über die grenze übernommen
wird irgendwann dass sie auch nicht zu
retten so dass wir als schreckliches
wort dass es nicht dazu kommt
und in diesem sinne russland wäre dann
auch vielen dank für den vielen dank für
berlin war ich also tatsächlich ein
schritt voran ist getan kleiner aber
schon ein wichtiges spiel
es war extrem and 14 punkte russland
sehr lenski möchte dann kompromisse
haben
und dazwischen ist dann irgendwo die
lösung ich will doch einfach noch um den
zeitpunkt der wahlen mal ohne mich davon
dass man sich jetzt nur auf eine
waffenruhe verständigt hat frau baerbock
mit putin ist in paris nicht so
wahnsinnig viel erreicht worden aber
wird es einen frieden in der ukraine
geben ohne ihn
nein definitiv nicht weil das sind ja
russische separatisten die den don was
besetzt haben die krim
die ist ja auch immer noch im raum über
die wird einfach gar nicht mehr geredet
natürlich muss man sich mit denjenigen
an tisch setzen die da einen krieg in
der ost ukraine führen und deswegen
finde ich es absolut richtig dass man
hier gerade in die gespräche wieder
eingestiegen ist allerdings muss man
auch klar sein was das minsker abkommen
beinhaltet und der allererste punkt
gerade um diesen krieg zu beenden ist
die schweren waffen abzuziehen und vor
allen dingen dass die truppen abgezogen
werden es hat in den letzten monaten und
das ist ja immer so auch außenpolitisch
und geraten gewisse kriege einfache aus
den tageszeitungen aus den news heraus
hat wieder die meisten angriffe von
separatisten gegeben für 10.000 menschen
sind im letzten jahr ums leben gekommen
und deswegen ist waffenruhe
waffenstillstand das allererste aber wir
sind noch lange nicht da dass die
menschen die da tag und nacht leiden in
sicherheit sind und deswegen muss dieses
format fortgeführt werden und was nicht
passieren kann und deswegen finde ich so
wichtig auch wenn über die sanktionen
nachher nochmal reden das darf kein
großen konflikt kein eingefroren der
konflikt wurde die menschen dann im
winter humanitäre not leiden dazu werden
wir gleich nachkommen vde auch das ist
interessant der französische präsident
scheint ja überzeugt davon zu sein dass
der besten im verhältnis zu russland in
der vergangenheit einige fehler gemacht
hat und unfair war betrachtet er selber
denn die ukraine wie die russen auch als
eine art puffer start
nein das denke ich nicht also die
französische wahrnehmung der situation
der ukraine ist nicht deckungsgleich mit
der russischen wahrnehmung das überhaupt
nicht aber in der französischen
diskussion seit ein paar jahren spricht
man immer immer immer wieder von fehlern
von dem westen wie sie gesagt haben
insbesondere in bezug auf die nato und
die osterweiterung genau natur
ost-erweiterung die als provokation für
moskau wahrgenommen worden ist und dass
das ist eigentlich in konservativen
lager sehr sehr verbreitet dass man ein
thema im wahlkampf für die
präsidentschaftswahl 2017
also das ist etwas das ist kein konsens
aber es ist schon ein thema das schon
eine wahrnehmung die bereite geteilt
wird und warum immer mehr sagt das auch
so
also er hat sich da entwickelt in dieser
haltung das war vor ein paar jahren
nicht so er sagt dass wir sagen dass
operation er stoiber und er würden sie
auch sagen es gehört zur wahrheit zu
sagen dass wir dann gegenüber den russen
nicht immer fair war
naja wenn ich mich wenn ich noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass putin hatte als
junger präsident im deutschen bundestag
2001 seine bemerkenswerte ewige gehabt
das war nun wirklich etwas neues die
hoffnung dass es möglicherweise in der
tat eine veränderung gibt ja vom
gemeinsamen europäischen haus gesprochen
er hat von einem anderen feld ist
senator gesprochen und man musste sich
ja mal auf einen funktion führen
das land habe fühlt sich natürlich und
ist der valida des kalten krieges
der westen hat den kalten krieg gewonnen
wenn ich das mal so zusammenfassen darf
und natürlich sind die entwicklungen
zusammenbruch des ostblocks des
warschauer paktes der warschauer pakt
die staaten rumänien bulgarien polen
tschechien der nato und es gibt es eines
da hat sich in der tat da haben wir
wahrscheinlich auch fehler gemacht ich
will jetzt nicht mehr gerichtlich zu
beweisen
und ich meine man kann das an einem
punkt festmachen als in der
amerikanischen auseinandersetzung mit
rande der frühere
der frühere kandidat der republikaner
den präsidenten obama angegriffen hat
und hat nie gefragt nach russland und
der gefahr
russlands für amerika und für die nato
und daraufhin hat obama einen
verhängnisvollen satz der in russland
wirklich gefühle bestätigt hat er gesagt
mit rami was willst du russland ist für
uns nur eine regionale macht da hat man
natürlich moskau
man muss ja auch die eigenen fehler
objektiv da liegen wir haben bestimmte
chancen die wir hatten um diese zeit
haben wir nicht genutzt wir haben auf
die stärke alleine gesetzt und amerika
hat sich natürlich auch verändert und
heute man muss ja auch mal sehen wer das
ist alles jetzt eine schreckliche
situation auf der anderen seite arbeitet
zb sankt petersburg an anderen 75 jahren
gedenken ende des zweiten kindes
und wenn ich mir mal vorstellen
die russische bevölkerung und da will
ich das wirklich objektiv darstellt die
russische bevölkerung umgekehrt dass es
in deutschland aus haben ein spezielles
verhältnis das die russen nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg sie haben das größte
opfer gebracht mit glaube ich 27
millionen toten
dass die russen heute ein so ein so
gutes verhältnis zu deutschland zur
deutschen bevölkerung haben und dass wir
uns in sankt petersburg bewegen können
obwohl wir da glaube ich über eine
million menschen
ausgehungert haben die gestorben sind
das und das ist auch ein kostbares gut
und das macht sich an einem bemerkbar
es kommt ja nicht von ungefähr dass die
deutsche bevölkerung bei allen umfragen
das können wir jetzt kritisieren bei
allen umfragen sagen die größere gefahr
putin ist nicht die große gefahr die
große gefahr ist dann verdrängt haben
die menschen in deutschland angst vor
den russen ich werde da muss ich ja auch
mal und jetzt muss ich die chance nutzen
und wenn ich das sagen hat der natürlich
in der tat jetzt die europäische karte
zieht und sagt was will ich denn hier
habe ich amerika auf den ich nicht mehr
so bauen kann
dort habe ich die auseinandersetzung
dem gedanken in china wollen wir
wirklich sagt manke wollen wir wirklich
genossen weiterhin in die chinesische
partnerschaft treiben oder so ist das
nicht ein langfristiger strategischer
partner auch für europa für ein starkes
europa mit einer genähten außenpolitik
das ist doch eine interessante idee
einer europäischen mission europa als
wirklich reichen ja funktioniert ja
einigermaßen sondern in der außenpolitik
einen und in der arien der
verteidigungspolitik sind wir weit
hinter den ansprüchen zurück was wir
eigentlich wollen und ich glaube da
haben wir keine unterschiedliche meinung
im wunsch europa muss gerade in diesen
feldern eine eine geschlossene haltung
mehrheit sichern habe komme ich immer
krohn natürlich jetzt ein echter der
bringt neuen schwung in die partie
hinein auge mit einer anzeige